before i take questions i'd like to wish
everyone a merry christmas and happy
holidays
this has been a uh one of the toughest
years we've ever faced as a nation
and the pandemic the economic crisis
calls for
racial justice historic and punishing
wildfires and storms so this season of
reflection carries a much deeper meaning
than it usually does
over 320 000 lives
lost to this virus and jill and i
send our prayers as i'm sure all of you
do to all who are facing this dark
winter
with an empty seat at the dinner table
where a loved one used to sit and talk
and laugh
reminisce our hearts go out to all of
you who have fallen on hard times
through no fault of your own i might add
unable to sleep at night
weigh down with the worry of what
tomorrow will bring for you
and for your family we're especially
grateful
for the healthcare workers on the front
lines the scientists
the researchers the clinical trial
participants on the front lines of the
vaccine
who deserve our thanks and who delivered
us scientific breakthrough
and for all of you who have deployed
family
deployed family members in the military
we know what it's like
we know what that experience is like how
difficult it can be
especially at this time of the year
our family knows your sacrifice and our
hearts are always with you
but keep the faith throughout this year
had to forego many of our favorite
holiday traditions
we have have as families as communities
and as a country
for the bidens we usually have 20 to 25
family members over for christmas dinner
and then the immediate family 14 of our
kids and grandkids and
their spouses for uh coming down the
stairs on christmas morning but not this
year
like we did over thanksgiving we all
have to care enough for each other that
we
have to stay apart just a little bit
longer
i know it's hard we have a long way to
go
but we're grateful that we've got the
vaccine
and yesterday in an effort to instill
some confidence in the vaccine
i had my shot administered in public and
i got a chance to thank all those nurses
and docs
at christiana hospital for what they've
been putting up with and doing for so
long
i look forward to the second shot and i
have absolute confidence in the vaccine
but we're in short supply taking the
vaccine from a vial
into the arm of millions of americans is
one of the biggest
operational challenges the united states
has ever faced
for 300 million people and we're going
to take
many more months for that to happen in
the meantime
this pandemic rages on experts
experts say things are going to get
worse before they get better
not withstanding the fact we have the
vaccine
as you all know we're averaging a death
rate of close to 3 000
people a day that means we're going to
lose tens of thousands of more lives in
the months to come
and the vaccine won't be able to stop
that
so we'll still have to remain vigilant
we need everyone to mask
up stay socially distanced
avoid large gatherings particularly
inside
we need to work in a bipartisan way
that's the only way we're going to get
through this in tough times
we have our first hint and glimpse of
bipartisanship i applaud the congress
their economic relief package and
included funding for vaccine
distribution
much needed temporary relief for workers
families and small businesses
in this election the american people
made it clear
they want us to reach across the aisle
and work together
on matters of national concern to get
something done
and i believe that to be the case from
the very beginning of my campaign and
i'm happy to see
members of congress heeding that message
as well from their own constituents
leaders in both house and senate both
parties
deserve credit for making the hard
compromises to get this done
well like all compromises it's far from
perfect
but it does provide vital relief at a
critical moment
however as i've said all along
this bill is just the first step
a down payment and addressing the crisis
the crises more than one that we're in
there's a lot more work to do
early next year i'm going to put forward
to the congress
my plans for what comes next we'll need
more help
to fully distribute the vaccine we're
going to need more testing
in order to be able to open our schools
we need more funding
to help firefighters and police many of
whom are being laid off as i speak
and the same with nurses risking their
lives on the front lines the same
for millions of hurting families who are
unable to put food on the table
pay rent or the mortgage
unemployment's extended for another 10
weeks it's going to take a lot longer
than that
but congress did its job this week
and i can and i must ask them to do it
again
next year but even with the changes in
approach
i'm going to put in place in late
january
people are still going to be getting
sick and dying from covert
one thing i promise you about my
leadership during this crisis
i'm gonna tell it to you straight i'm
gonna tell you the truth
and here's the simple truth our darkest
days
in the battle against covet are ahead of
us
not behind us so we need to prepare
ourselves
to steal our spines as frustrating it is
to hear
it's going to take patience persistence
and determination to beat this virus
there'll be no time to waste in taking
the steps we need
to turn this crisis around my
administration will start to do this
its part on our first day in office
with masking requirements a new strategy
for testing
accelerated protection protective gear
and we're going to challenge congress
and the american people
to step up immediately as well
to do their part as of the relief bill
passed by congress there's another
challenge
which my administration will confront on
a bipartisan basis
a massive cyber security breach
against the u.s companies many of them
as well as federal agencies and there's
still
so much we don't know including the full
scope of the breach
or the extent of the damage it has
caused but we know this
much this attack constitutes a
grave risk to our national security
it was carefully planned and carefully
orchestrated
it was carried out by using
sophisticated cyber tools
the attackers succeeded in catching the
federal government off guard and
unprepared
foreign actors have been working in this
breach since last
late last year at least last year
setting the landscape to compromise our
systems
scraping up sensitive information from
our world-class tech sector
and from private businesses and from
united states government agencies
the truth is this the trump
administration
failed to prioritize cyber security
it did that from eliminating or
downgrading cyber coordinators
in both the white house and at the state
department to firing the director of
cyber space and infrastructure security
agency
to president trump's irrational
downplaying of the seriousness of this
attack
enough's enough in an age when so much
of our lives are conducted online
cyber attacks must be treated as a
serious threat
by our leadership the highest levels
we can't let this go unanswered that
means making clear
and publicly who is responsible for the
attack
and taking meaningful steps to hold them
in account
initial indications including from
secretary pompeo
secretary of state and attorney general
william barr suggest that russia
russia is responsible for this breach
it certainly fits russia's long history
of reckless disruptive cyber activities
but the trump administration needs to
make an official attribution
this assault happened on donald trump's
watch
when he wasn't watching it's still his
responsibility as president
to defend american interest for the next
four weeks
but rest assured that even if he does
not take it seriously i
will well i'm disappointed by the
response of president trump i was
pleased to see leaders
in both parties in the congress speak
out loudly and clearly
on this attack again i want to thank
prominent republicans in the senate
particularly for speaking out it's a
sign
a sign that with the new administration
we can confront these threats
on a bipartisan basis with a united
front
here at home that should be encouraging
the american people
and a warning to our adversaries in the
meantime
the president's team for the next four
weeks need to cooperate
fully which they haven't been doing to
share information that becomes available
on both the impact and our response
to ensure a smooth transition
to protect the american people as
administrations change
over the next month i intend to continue
focusing on building my team
so the right people are in place on day
one of my administration
to take over this effort to prioritize
cyber security across the board
and i'll consult with experts to plan
for the steps that my administration
will take
in order to secure our systems improve
our cyber defenses
and to better withstand future attacks
that we know will come
and to impose cost on those who conduct
them
and i fully expect bipartisan support
from this based on what we've heard so
far
our adversaries are highly capable cyber
threats are among the greatest threats
to our global security
in the 21st century i believe we have to
treat them with the same seriousness of
purpose
we treated threats of other
unconventional weapons
if the work of their allies to establish
clear
international rules and mechanisms would
force them
and consequences for those countries
that violate them i want to close with
this
as i look at the first of what will be
millions of vaccinations
going in the arms of americans after
hundreds
of thousands of lives lost
a congress finally passing an economic
relief package after months and months
of delay
at a new urgency for a bipartisan
approach to cyber security after years
of a president
who refused to stand up to our
adversaries and hold them accountable
i'm reminded of the quote this season
from a jesuit priest named alfred delt
he wrote quote advent is a time for
rousing
delp believed that first we are shaken
to our depths
and then we're ready for a season of
hope
as a nation we've certainly been shaken
to our depths this year
now it's time to awaken to get moving
time for hope we've gotten through tough
times before in this nation
we'll get through these difficult times
as well
and we'll do it by coming together by
working with one another
by being you've heard me say many times
but we are at our best
the united states of america there are
certain things that rise way above
partisan differences
that threaten the united states there
are
national security interests that require
us to cooperate
and i'm confident i'm confident we'll be
able to do that
after a year of pain and loss it's time
to unite
to heal to rebuild
for all those who are suffering right
now
who've had enormous loss lie awaken
night wonder in tomorrow's brain i'd say
well god bless you all and i promise you
we're going to continue to push as hard
as we can
to finish the job may god bless you all
may god protect our troops merry
christmas and happy holidays to you all
and i'll be happy to take some questions
megan i'll let you
tell me who's
thank you mr president-elect president
obama once referred to
this emerging cyber battlefield as the
wild west president trump been
commenting on this most recent breach
said the situation was well under
control given what you just said about
this
that it represents a grave risk do you
believe it also represents an
act of war and will you respond in kind
if so
the answer is first of all it is a grave
risk and it continues
i see no evidence that it's under
control
i've seen none heard of none defense
department won't even brief us
on many things so i know of nothing
that suggests it's under control this
president hasn't even identified
who's responsible yet number two
the question of the damage done
remains to be determined we have to look
at very closely
the nature of the breaches how extensive
they are
and what damage has been done and
thirdly
there's going to be a necessity as
president obama and i and our
administration talked about
we need international society
international
rules of the road on cyber security we
have to bring along our allies
and our friends so we hold everyone
accountable
who breaches any of these basic
fundamental rules
and lastly i believe that
when i learn the extent of the damage
and in fact who is formally responsible
they can be assured that we will respond
and probably responding kind there's
many options which i will not
discuss now why not lay out those kind
of options publicly though
isn't part of the issue here deterrence
and the fact that russia felt some
impunity if it is indeed russia to do
what they've done here
we have not done that in any other areas
where we have faced international crises
we don't sit here and say that we are
going to
strike you with a nuclear weapon we
don't sit and we're going to say
and so on let us determine what the
extent of the damage is
and i promise you there'll be a response
on another issue sir as you know the
runoff elections in georgia could well
determine whether there's a democratic
senate
in january or a republican senate in
january is the
are you waiting for the outcome of those
two races to make some of the final
selections for your cabinet including uh
the attorney general the most
significant outstanding
uh cabinet secretary you have to pick no
not based on the attorney general it's
just a matter of getting to it through
it
and being able to announce them all
they'll all be announced either just
before or just
after we're going to make an
announcement tomorrow and we may have
another announcement between then and
christmas christmas and new year's
we're just working through all of the
efforts to uh
to do due diligence and lastly has the
issue of the investigation
of your son come up in discussions with
your team and with potential
candidates about attorney general no i
guarantee you
i'm going to do what i said the attorney
general of the united states of america
is not
the president's lawyer i will appoint
someone who i expect to enforce the law
as the law is written not guided by me
thank you sir
thank you mr president-elect there is
growing concern today
about that new variant of uh copen 19
sweeping across the uk
should the united states right now
impose a travel ban
on flights coming in from the uk as you
know there already is one
unrelated to that finding that new
strain number one
and uh the question is whether or not at
the very least
it only allows americans coming home
to be able to come back to the states
citizens
one of the things i'm waiting to get a
response from my
cova team is whether or not we should
require
testing before they get on an aircraft
to fly home number one
and number two when they get home should
they quarantine that's my instinct but
i'm
waiting to hear from my experts right
now you talked about how you want to
propose a new
code relief plan when you do take office
it took
more than six months for congress to
reach this new deal americans
are suffering at this moment how can you
assure americans
that relief will come and come soon you
all ask your most interesting questions
have you ever known anyone in the
history of the united states of america
that could be president and assure
exactly what the congress is going to do
so i can't assure anything but i can
tell you what i expect
i fully expect on those critical issues
that we're facing
number one being able to get all
the work we need done and all the
funding
to be able to get that vaccine in
everyone's arm and that's 300 million
people
we'll get that done because you're going
to see that the responsibility has
already been recognized by the
republicans and democrats in the
congress
because the constituency is going to
demand it
number one number two all those people
are out there hurting
lost jobs for no fault of their own
they've extended unemployment for 10
weeks
simply not sufficient necessary to get
it done to get through the holidays
but i predict you will get cooperation
and get that done
i've been arguing from the very
beginning and told how
i love it it makes me sound so much
younger how naive i am
uh about how the congress works i think
i've been proven right
wrong across the board the things that
are left to deal with from employment
to people needing unemployment insurance
to the ability to have access to health
care
to be able to get this they treat
treatment for free etc
all of that is something that the public
is not going to stand for
us not doing and i think with donald
trump
not in the way that will also enhance
the prospect of things getting done
will your plan include a new round of
stimulus checks to the american people
and if so for how much
well look that's a that's a negotiated
issue
but it will yes it will and i think by
the way i think we uh
owe bernie sanders and his republican
colleagues
thanks for getting not all the stimulus
we looked for 1200 but getting 600 done
i think you're seeing that there is a
clear understanding
that these issues go beyond any ideology
people are desperately hurting and the
republicans are hurting as badly as
democrats
there are a few people and i'm not
saying they're responsible for any of
this
a few people are doing extremely well in
that case-shaped recovery
and and they're doing fine but they
still need
access to the vaccines they still need
access
to making sure that we are able to
handle
crises in the hospitals etc so i think
they're
on the things relating to a vaccine
distribution which is going to cost
billions more dollars it's simply going
to cost
billions more dollars we need national
standards layout to help governors
deserve
how they're going to get that vaccine
throughout their throughout their
communities number one number two
we're going to need to take care of
those people who through no fault of
their own
are unemployed they've worked like hell
but they have no job because of the
coveted crisis
and thirdly we're going to have to begin
to rebuild the country we can't wait
we can't wait to rebuild the economy
we're gonna have to start doing that now
on infrastructure programs and a whole
range of other things
i think the uh sort of the dawn is
broken on the vast majority of people
there are still people who don't want to
help
there's still people who are insisting
my way or the highway
but the vast majority of the members of
congress i believe will be able to work
out those
those uh specific issues that are of
national consequence
thank you mr president thank you
mr president-elect thank you thank you
i'm still not sure if i heard you say
specifically though sir what is your ask
of the congress in just one month's time
what is your ask of the congress after
you've
have watched over these many months when
people in your party as well
did not um necessarily act as quickly
as some americans would have liked what
is your ask sir my ask will be laid out
there in detail but it relates to four
things
number one making sure we have all the
money we need
to get the vaccine to 300 million
americans at a minimum over the next
year
the next calendar year number one number
two
making sure that all those people who
are unemployed through no fault of their
own because of the covet crisis
and small businesses and big businesses
etc shutting down
that they continue to be able to live
day-to-day
they don't engage in food shortages
they're not in a position where they get
thrown out of their homes
i would also be asking for a moratorium
on
being evicted from your homes for
failure to pay rent
moratoriums on relating to the issue of
whether or not your mortgage are being
paid
thirdly i think it's critically
important we provide
all of the ppe as well as the direct
payments to small bid businesses and
others to be able to stay open
to be able to keep their people employed
that is something that's going to
increase as time moves
and lastly we're going to need to make
sure that we're in a position
that we can provide for the opportunity
for people to begin to go back to work
and get new jobs developing
infrastructure
given the narrow majorities in the house
and senate you've watched many
administrations come and go do you
believe that you will have a honeymoon
to get things i don't think it's a
honeymoon at all i think it's a
nightmare that everybody's going through
and they all say it's gotta end
it's not a honeymoon they're not doing
me a favor
i'll ask you a rhetorical question i
don't expect you to answer
and that is do you think that
republicans who are losing their
businesses do you think
republican constituents out there who
can't pay their mortgage do you think
they're not letting their republican
representatives know they got a problem
do you think the person who just lost
some a family member
and is worried about losing another one
who happens to be a republican a staunch
republican
isn't telling his or her republican
senator or state representative you've
got to help you've got to get something
done
do you think all those people who are
making judgments of whether or not
i'm my child will be able to go to
school and i have to stay home
and i can't go to work therefore i have
no income are all democrats
i think there's been a dawning here and
look
you have a different team in town you
have a different team in town
i'm not going to villainize the
opposition but i'm going to stand and
say this is what we got to do because
they know it
they know it it's not like i'm saying
what we want to do is we want to make
sure that
we are going to sign a new
trade agreement with a b or c
this is life and death that's why i
believe we'll get it done
sir frank task of follow-up to the
attorney general decision
you and president obama selected eric
holder on december 1st
every recent president has selected
their
attorney general by this point what is
taking you so long to make this critical
decision and do you believe that this is
a time
in the post-trump era where you need
someone who
is not steeped in politics who may have
a life's work
above or beyond politics the answer is
first of all we've done we've gone
faster than everybody in the total
cabinet
so we not president obama yourself sir
the whole cabinet
the whole cabinet oh captain well there
were a few missteps on commerce as you
remember but
i i do i didn't want to raise them
though um
but look um this is uh
we're looking for a team
who will instill the greatest confidence
in the professionals at doj
to know once again that there is no
politics
there's no politics as you know there's
been
a great debate about in every single
appointment
whether or not people there are enough
african-americans enough
uh hispanics enough asian pacific
americans enough
people who have are new and young so
we're just working through it it's not
by design
there's not an obvious choice in my mind
thank you sir thank you merry christmas
merry christmas
hey um you just spoke about
uh your confidence that there will it'll
be possible to get things done
once president trump has left office
excuse me not just because he left
office because
it's all becoming obvious exactly what's
at stake
right but but even so are you concerned
about the effects
long term that his presidency and and
now in the transition
his refusal to concede his challenges to
the election will have on american
politics will have on the republican
party
especially if he does take the step of
filing for reelection next month
running to run in 2024 um you know
are you concerned about him lingering
around i know i see you smiling but
a soft ask it and um kind of a cruel
urie to that
um would you consider filing for
re-election early next year to show that
you're not going to be a lame doc
i'm not going to be a lame duck just
watch me just watch me i've been saying
this from the very beginning
look let's just get the work from this
point on
for the next several years there is one
objective
and it's not my political future it's
better in the circumstances for the
average american
that's what it's all about and i want to
communicate to the american people what
i hope they already understand about me
it's about them it's not about me it's
not about me
still do you think that the climate will
be different after president trump than
it was
well we'll see i i i don't know i mean
i'm not a fortune teller but i can tell
you that
the calls i've gotten from sitting
republicans
in powerful positions they know me they
know i level with them they know i never
mislead
they know i tell them the truth and they
know i don't go out of my way to try to
embarrass
um and in terms of the transition are
there areas
where the trump team has not been
cooperative that
um have not been made public we've heard
a bit about the issues at the the
pentagon last week
are there other areas that you think the
public should be aware of
there are other areas i'm not sure it's
relevant whether the public should be
aware of look what i'm trying to do
is pull together the political parties
that are in the congress that
know that we're facing four serious
crises
and we have to address all of them none
of us should get all we want
but we can make real progress and so my
focus is on uniting
not emphasizing the divisions thank you
thank you mr president-elect um russia
as you said is suspected of carrying out
this massive
cyber hack um you said it happened under
president donald trump's
watch but of course in january 21 it
will then of course land on your
doorstep
my question is what are they right let's
get something straight will land on my
doorstep his failure will land on my
doorstep
yes okay what are the practical
implications of overseeing a government
where
experts say it could take years to know
where the hackers went and years to
remove them
how can you ensure that the systems will
be safe given what experts are saying
i can't ensure but i can demand based on
the
experts both here and among our allies
what is needed to find that out it may
cost literally billions of dollars to
secure our cyberspace
it may take a great deal to get it done
first and foremost it takes people who
are
knowledgeable and vigilant about what is
happening and how it's happening
and so i'm just going to do all that
need be done
all that need be done to determine a the
extent of the damage
b the nature of how it occurred see
what i should be doing internally in
terms of my administration to protect
against it in the future
and number four getting together with
our allies
to try to set up an international system
of what constitutes
appropriate behavior in cyberspace and
get us all to get to the point where we
hold
all hold any other country liable for
the breaking out of those basic rules
and just be clear at the top of that did
you say you couldn't ensure that the
systems would be safe when you came into
office then
of course i can't i don't know what the
state of them is they're clearly not
safe right now
and then between now and january 20th
the likelihood of my being able to
garner all the information the extent
and depth of the violations
exactly how the codes or how it were
breached
what was breached what was done is not
within my power to do that but it will
be
an overwhelming focus for my
administration
and my other question is on immigration
um i was
just reading about the fact that
officials in
your transition jake sullivan susan rice
they say you won't be immediately
rolling back
trump immigration policies and i i
stress immediately
there are some immigration advocates who
say why not roll back
the remaining mexico policy why not roll
back the
asylum restrictions what is your
timeline for rolling back some of the
specific
trump administration immigration
policies we've already started
discussing these issues with the
president of mexico
and our friends in latin america
and the timeline is to do it so that we
in fact
make it better not worse the last thing
we need is to say we're going to
stop immediately the uh you know
the access to asylum the way it's being
run now
and end up with 2 million people on our
border
it's a matter of setting up the guard
rails so we can move the direction
i will accomplish what i said i would do
a much more humane policy based on
family unification
but it requires getting a lot in place
and requires getting the funding to get
in place
including just asylum judges for example
so it's a matter of it will get done
and it will get done quickly but it's
not going to be able to be done on day
one lift every restriction
that exists and find out that and go
back to what it was
20 years ago and all of a sudden find
out we have a crisis on our hand that
complicates what we're trying to do
would you say to immigration what would
you say to immigration advocates then
who say maybe you're possibly dragging
your feet too
it might take too long or you it sounds
like you're saying
look at me i've never told them anything
i haven't done
i'm working with them now we're dealing
with some of those very organizations as
we speak
and i will do what i said it's going to
take not day one
it's going to take probably the next six
months to put that in place
thank you so much thank you merry
christmas everybody
thank you
yes yes yes god love you man you're a
one-horse opponent
i tell you thank you thank you
i promise you my justice department will
be totally on its own
making his judgments about how they
should proceed thank you
you